The public transportation in Switzerland is just incredible.
The ticket system is based on the honor system.
So after you buy an all-day pass or a one-hour ticket, that's it, you're done.
No one's standing there to check your ticket at the door.
Just hop onto the bus or tram and you're good to go.
I was just baffled by this.
Obviously, some people take advantage and don't pay for tickets,...
...but that's why they do occasionally have workers checking for tickets.
A whole ten days of traveling around and we never got checked once.
I've heard you can go years without being checked.
But the one day you figure it's safe to not buy a ticket...
...because you're only going a short distance...
...would of course be the day there are two guys on the tram...
...waiting for you to check your ticket.
And it's a very serious 100-franc fine if you get caught.
So, don't get caught.